the other thing that I want to talk
about is actually some good news and
that is Donald Trump's accountability
the March for consequence for Donald
Trump continues
there is news that the former publisher
of the National Enquirer I believe his
name is David pecker is now speaking to
the grand jury in Manhattan that has
been impaneled surrounding the hush
money payments made to Stormy Daniels
I'm going to read a little bit from this
New York Times article entitled
Manhattan prosecutors begin presenting
Trump case to Grand Jury The Manhattan
District Attorney's decision represents
a dramatic escalation of the inquiry and
potentially sets the case on a path
forward toward criminal charges against
the former president
this is what we need we need fewer
business uh cases that result in 1.61
million dollar fines for an extensive I
mean he claims to be a billionaire even
if he's not he's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars a single one and a
half million dollar fine isn't going to
be much of a bump in the road for Donald
Trump it's certainly not going to
dissuade him or deter him from his uh
criminal activity but this might when
there's actual criminality and jail time
on the line the Manhattan District
Attorney's office on Monday began
presenting evidence to a grand jury
about Donald J Trump's role in paying
hush money to a porn star during his
2016 presidential campaign laying the
groundwork for potential criminal
charges against the former president in
the coming months according to people
with knowledge of the matter the grand
jury was recently impaneled and the
beginning of witness testimony
represents a clear signal that the the
district attorney Alvin L Bragg is
nearing a decision about whether to
charge Mr Trump on Monday one of the
witnesses was seen with his lawyer
entering the building in lower Manhattan
where the grand jury is sitting the
witness David pecker is the former
publisher of the National Enquirer the
Tabloid that helped broker the deal with
the porn star Stormy Daniels now if you
remember this case
you will know that the well there's a
there's a term called I believe it's
catch and kill where a journalist Outlet
like this will offer money to buy the
rights to the story and then do nothing
with it but they the the person they
work with Stormy Daniels in this case
would sign an NDA not allowing them to
ever tell the story again because the
rights to that story were owned by the
by the newspaper I'm using that very
Loosely here with the National Enquirer
and that seems to be something along the
lines of what was dealt with here with
Donald Trump and Michael Cohen who by
the way pled guilty pleaded guilty to
these charges there was criminality here
that has been proven there have been
convictions related to this but just not
Donald Trump
as prosecutors prepare to reconstruct
the events surrounding the payment for
Grand jurors they have sought to
interview several witnesses including
the tabloid's former editor Dylan Howard
and two employees at Mr Trump's company
the people said Mr Howard and the Trump
organization employees Jeffrey
McConaughey and Deborah tesseroff have
not yet testified before the grand jury
the prosecutors have also begun
contacting officials from Mr Trump's
2016 campaign one of the people said and
in a sign that they want to corroborate
these witness accounts the prosecutors
recently subpoenaed phone records and
other documents that might shed light on
the episode a conviction is not a sure
thing in part because a case could hinge
on showing that Mr Trump and his company
falsified records to hide the payout
from voters days before the 2016
election a low-level felony charge that
would be based on largely untested legal
Theory the case would also rely on the
testimony of Michael D Cohen Mr Trump's
former fixer who made the payment and
who he himself pleaded guilty to federal
charges related to the hush money in
2018. so listen I I don't understand the
trepidation from The New York Times
reporting here because we have a guilty
we have a conviction in the case related
you think Michael Cohen was making hush
money payments for Donald Trump out of
the goodness of his own heart out of his
own pockets
come on
this is something to follow Donald Trump
is in dire need of legal
consequence for his actions in dire need
of consequence for his crimes whether it
be this whether it be obstruction of
justice whether it be inciting an
Insurrection against the United States
of America but it has to start somewhere
and I'm glad that Alvin Bragg is back on
the case after kind of shying away from
the initial charges I'm glad that this
is before a grand jury that is where it
starts and hopefully that's where we're
going to get some traction
once again my name is Jesse dollarmore
you can subscribe to me on YouTube just
search Jesse dollar more or dollar more
daily you can also follow me on on
Instagram on Twitter on Tick Tock all
across the social media just search at
dollar more and of course you can
subscribe to my podcast my twice weekly
podcast co-hosted by the lovely and
talented Brittany page it's called I
doubt it
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the best place to find and watch
documentaries on politics history
science technology nature you name it
they have it curiosity stream has a
deeper collection of documentaries than
any other streaming service they add new
titles every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below